so if you are driving out to Riverside I
don't know if you're working a full day
and then you're having to get in your
car but that hands-on approach versus
this thing I keep throwing out which is
the red carpet producer and I know I'm
making light of it but I remember when
he told it to me years ago and I never
forgot it totally and I wonder if you
could just explain yeah he was what what
it is well so there was a very my former
mentor who told me that there were a lot
of producers out there that want to have
their name in a film you know and they
want to walk the red carpet with a
starlet and you know it's kind of more
it's a more sort of status thing as
opposed to the the producer that will be
married to that project for the rest of
their life and gave me some examples of
that so the red carpet producer I mean
is the one that you know it's it's the
glamor life it's the it's the one where
you know you're you're sort of just
there is a figure that you were a part
of this yes but you were just sort of
there to cash in on the on the
experience of it as opposed to the
filmmaking process and that's not every
producer but there are a ton of them out
there they you know they'll help make a
movie and they'll put their name in the
credits and and they really just want
the kind of the social benefits of all
of that to kind of play and do their
thing I don't know if that is that
answer that it does I was thinking if
someone though comes with a checkbook
and I know this sounds very assertive
callous but and they you know that
that's their very defined role and they
are like yes I have the money I just
want to invest in this then I feel like
they get a pass but not everybody comes
with that I realized right and there are
a lot of red carpet you insert any title
yeah there's a lot of people in there
they just want to you know say they made
a movie and and that's fine you know but
it's it's it's not producing I don't
think there there are line producers who
are amazing people and there are
creative producers that are amazing for
you and there are executive producers
that are amazing people but if you just
show up with it I mean obviously if
somebody came to me with money and said
hey we want to invest but I'd really it
really had to be though that we have
shared shared principles sort of in the
sense that like Who I am as a person I
don't want to just be taking somebody's
money not knowing who they are not
knowing I mean I wouldn't get involved I
wouldn't start a business with you right
unless you and I Karen kind of like
talked through some things and kind of
go oh yeah we feel kind of the same way
about this world and sure you're
bringing X and I'm bringing Y to this to
this vision that we're gonna create and
do something but if somebody's just
showing up handing money and you just
don't you know it looks like mmm and
they're flipping about it yeah sounds
good yeah yeah yeah oh it's a great idea
you know keep me posted keep me posted I
mean I I've met so many of those people
that like they'd literally walk around
and actually the the thing that kicked
off when our fantasy girl was I now
believed that that's what we had we had
a person like that I've even offered
money before like lots of money through
debt instruments you'll hear about that
that term a lot and and it can get
really tricky because ultimately the the
loan that you're taking out to finance
your movie it's on you to repay Oh God
and it's know so it's not it's not
really financing in terms of venture
capital which is risk it's I'm gonna get
paid whether this movie makes money or
not and it'll be off of your back and
your name is on the loan it's not the
person providing the financing we've
we've looked at all the paperwork and
there are there are many different
instruments out there they're there you
know that are backed by banks and in
reality for an independent film producer
this is this is one of the dangers I
don't think there's been many people
that have done this but when you're a
big studio and you have a whole slate of
movies and you can afford to lose money
in some
where others will make up for the the
losses of the other you can play that
game when you're talking about one movie
and five million dollars and five
million dollars being in your name and
you're responsible for paying that back
within a certain number of years
irregardless of how the film turns out
irregardless if a distributor buys your
movie up only to hold it I mean there's
all sorts of things that can go wrong
that prevent you from getting that and
though that money back so it's best to
work with people who share your vision
who believe that you're capable of
implementing this goal this dream this
thing you have not just on a business
plan but when they sit across from you
and they're asking you questions like a
smart investor would who's cautious
where they're gonna put their money that
they're not just out there ready to sign
up and you know let's make your movie
but yet at the same time there isn't
this other process that it goes through
its kind of back to that validation when
you're a young actor out here and
somebody say hey you got a good look hop
in the car you know but it's the same
it's the same thought process you you
you if you're investing money into a
film you want to know who you're getting
involved with on both sides of that
table because in at the end of the day
if everything goes wrong you don't want
to be countersued or you don't want to
sue you don't want to countersue you'd
rather go hey we tried we're gonna you
know it didn't work you know this is it
was all written out obviously you do the
contracts and everything else and
everybody knows what what the investor
and the credited investor is and all
that kind of stuff
but at the end of the day you don't want
to have troubles when things don't go
right you want to be able to you know go
hey we all got in this together we have
the best intentions working together
we're people and we you know I need you
you need me if this is what we want to
do to make money or tell this story or
both hopefully and and if it doesn't go
the way we think it is then we have to
learn from it and move on that's what
investors that's what good investors do
the good investors are
people who have made bad investments and
they've learned from making those bad
investments what not to do the next time
around makes them a little bit more
cautious maybe a little bit more cynical
but the only thing that you have at that
point is just yourself and what you're
bringing to the table and if that person
sees you as a values to what they're
trying to achieve and go yeah you you
reflect all of the qualities that I'm
looking for in people that I know in
other industries who invest in products
and materials and businesses you share
the same qualities that these
entrepreneurs do and and those are the
kind of relationships that I want to go
forward with and I've been very blessed
to have those I learned a lot of lessons
early on red carpet producer ready to
write that check keep me posted you know
and and nothing is on the record ever
you you will know like they can never
put anything in writing for you
everything will be a phone call let's
have a conversation yeah let's talk
about it a phone calls no good and
especially as you get closer to meeting
their their their stated demands or not
demands but objectives that they need to
have in place in order for that
investment to happen what a lot of these
guys do is they as they get people like
you and me around and they will they'll
get a retainer from somebody they get a
monthly retainer to pitch projects so if
you've got somebody who's willing to get
involved with you and you are getting a
retainer from a group that's looking to
do the financing the whether it be the
bank or the banker or somebody else what
they're doing is they're basically
presenting you a slate of projects and
the status reports every month and
saying here's where we're moving on this
as if this date will have this and if
projects come and go and drop off well
then these people are getting that money
to vet them saying well they you know
whatever reason they make up to this
individual and meanwhile they could be
telling you everything is going fine and
yeah yeah we've seen that a couple of
times it's a it's a con and it's a scam
but the the real con is the one that
they're doing and they're getting the
retainer for the the the worst one is
when the filmmaker commits
and has done so through a process really
where there's no verified paper trail if
anything that's been said or and yeah
it's bad it's bad I I tell pretty people
if you can't put something in writing
with anybody yeah
don't get involved with them that's a
red flag
you